hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome to today's video on uh
Tuesday September 27th and I want to
talk about is you know trap Traders
because you know there's different types
of trap Traders and you know the way you
trade it is the same but the way you
would you would look at it is slightly
different okay because you know one is
often caused by stops getting triggered
the other one is often caused by
liquidity coming into the market and
today there's there's a couple of great
examples all right so you know this
morning 7 46 we made a new high in the S
PS
okay we're coming up making these new
highs and then you're getting these two
binding balances up here at the top
right even one tick below it's the 75
okay so it's 44 against 75 one against
144 zero against 19. you know so you're
looking at about uh you know you know
close to about 240 250 contracts
a trading up here on the offer side with
very little counter trade right the zero
the one and you know are these Traders
trapped yes they are okay now
when you're seeing these this heavy
volume up in here now this this is where
it gets interesting because this volume
up here in my opinion this was caused by
probably a stop order that got triggered
here maybe around the 27 area right that
triggered it up Market immediately
um came off from that area and then just
sort of rotated around the 25 26 area
over the next couple bars and you
couldn't continue up what I consider
these people trapped yes I would now I
gotta remember though if it's a stop
getting triggered up here I I don't
really think it was a buy stop to get in
you know sort of like a trend follower
person I I think it was probably just a
stop to protect
um a short that was put on because
again you're not seeing the follow
through right if I'm seeing these
stacked bind imbalances coming in or
well these aren't stacked but this is
um buying a balances coming in at new
highs of the day I'm looking for follow
through if I don't get that follow
through the trade for me is to the short
side
and it's sold off okay sold off from the
20s you know down into the
what do you want to call it the
060708 area and then eventually when
cash opened 832 we rallied back up made
new highs in very similar High okay let
me open this chart up a bit
came up here made a new high you got a
nice stack behind a balance going into
the high as you as you after you took it
out and then another stack buying a
balance at right at the new high right
76 79 91 excuse me 90.
and uh what is that 203 okay so you know
maybe about 500 contracts trading right
up here at the high with very little
counter trade zero zero zero twenty
three
all right so I kind of stacked buying a
balance at the High
what does that mean well it means
there's obviously aggressive buyers now
is it are people fomoing into the market
maybe most likely this was a stop that
got triggered right you got to recognize
how a stop looks like when it gets
executed in the market it often sweeps
right through the market because you
know a stop as soon as it gets triggered
it just takes one contract to trigger a
stop
the whole order is going to execute as a
market order and that's why oftentimes
at highs or lows you see
you know these these sort of I don't
call it a tail you know this is just a
stop order getting triggered boom then
it came right back down and then starts
trading sideways doesn't even take out
that high that's how I know is probably
a stop to most likely protect
a short position that was put on earlier
someone thinking the market was going
down and you know they're stopped out
okay now are these trap Traders well if
someone's getting out of position you're
not going to consider them trapped right
trap Trader you would consider somebody
that's fomoing into the market oh my God
I don't want to miss out of this move
and they're coming in then you'd
consider a trap but if I have a strong
feeling that this is a stop order that
got triggered
then I'm not going to really consider it
you know being trapped but it's leaving
a footprint in the market that would
look like trap Traders okay but you can
still trade it even though it's not
something that's being trapped you know
that you know you reach someone's sort
of breaking point right they're taking
too much heat
and they got out of the position fact
that we couldn't move any higher right
they see 500 contracts of aggressive
buying in Market can't move higher
what's the trade to the short side
where's your stop just above that stack
buying a balance right because normally
this is bullish now I know someone's I
know there's another company out there
selling software that basically just
buying stacked buying imbalances and
selling Stacks stacked selling
imbalances right but as you can see even
if you bought this stack buying a
balance yeah I went a little bit higher
here but if you bought this stack buying
a balance you would have been stopped
out
okay well you need that follow through
order flow right because remember
you may have a view of the market but if
nobody else has that view of the market
well who's going to move the market in
your favor no one
right you're gonna put your position on
you know as a retail Trader you know
we're gonna put our
five
ten contracts on but if nobody else has
the same view of the market like not
even has to be the same reason but just
be bullish or be bearish the Market's
not going to move in your direction so
you got some very bullish activity here
here and here right two stack buying
imbalances in the same bar as we're
making the new highs okay does anybody
else think this Market is bullish no uh
what you're starting to see now is
aggressive selling come in right next
bar strong negative Delta so you went
from
a bar with very strong positive Delta
Two thousand one hundred twenty two the
Min Delta was Zero then the next bar
Max Delta zero what's your where's your
net aggressive bind it's not present
instead you've got Min Delta of minus
Max dealt uh sorry final Delta minus
676. so you went from
zero Min Delta to zero Max Delta
what do you think the market is going to
be doing they went from a bar that was
very bullish a lot of buying to now a
bar that's very bearish right remember
you know markets changed on a dime for
whatever reason you know something comes
out ideas Traders ideas of the market
perceptions change
this is what order flow allows you to
pick up on right it allows you to pick
up that little Nuance that you went from
all Max Delta to almond Delta even the
next bar you know the Min Delta is minus
1200 we close the Delta at minus 11.98
so almost you know two contracts off our
Min Delta and very small maxed Alpha 70.
and again lower right what's the trade
what's the downside right and Market
breaks in the next couple of minutes you
know it breaks about eight points right
and then eventually you may pull back a
little bit and then sold kept selling
off obviously we sold off you know close
to 100 points off this High I mean I
wouldn't have predicted that we'd sell
off 100 points from this high but this
is a nice
place to get short because you have all
that aggressive buying but zero follow
through okay so are these Traders
trapped yeah that's a borderline you
know
Traders being trapped this afternoon
there's a much better example here
coming in around the
oh where is it here
right in here I drew the lines in here
because look at this 37 sorry 36 68
is the opening price okay so this area
36.65 I drew these lines in after I
started seeing that volume coming in but
just give you an idea
right of where it's coming in it's
coming in an area that we had been
trading back and forth for you know
since 140 all the way up until two
o'clock
okay let me see we go above it below it
above it below it so we're training
right around it and then boom all of a
sudden someone came in said that's it
here's two and a half thousand contracts
on the offer it was more actually but
boom you can see it trades 315 on the
offer 213.
another 700 so you're looking at 1300
another
1096 so basically Eleven Hundred so
you know 2 300 contracts here now These
Guys these are the ones that are really
getting trapped because they're being
absorbed okay these are traders that are
being absorbed by a big
limit offer right someone with Supply in
the market it's like yeah sure you know
I'm happy to sell it happy to keep my
foot on the market so to speak okay and
you can see every time it comes up here
it comes off comes up comes off another
261 trades here finally it breaks These
Guys these guys are are the Trap Traders
here so you know about two and a half
thousand contracts trade can't get
through it you know at some point these
are the guys that you're looking to puke
out not the
person that got stopped out of a
position because you know they're
probably not in that position but if
these 2 000 contracts
if these guys in here are thinking you
know this Market is going higher and
they just keep buying it thinking it's
going higher at some point they're going
to realize
that
Market's not going any higher and
they're going to turn Sellers and get
out and that's going to add pressure to
the market whereas
those those highs earlier right this is
just a stop right most likely a stop to
get out of a position okay that person's
out right you're not worried about you
know these guys that are short up here
you know the guys that had the offers in
the market that got filled they're short
they don't they're not trapped I mean
they're happy days you know they're
smiling all the way to the bank they
sold literally the highs of the day
okay and they said if it's a stop it's
just someone getting out of that
position now if it's a stop to get into
a position
uh
you're only talking 500 contracts 500
contracts is about traded ten thousand
eight thousand to eight thousand two
hundred it's it's not heavy volume the
way that we're seeing the heavy volume
you know later here
all right the two and a half thousand
contracts you know it's enough to sort
of keep a lid on the market and keep
that perception that there's Supply up
here at 65.
as this Market sells off from 65 down
into the 40s right I mean we did come
back up finally
um a little bit later just uh ahead of
the cash close
and you know where are we right now you
know we're trading just just below it so
I know that there was Supply up here at
uh 65 enough to to absorb whatever
buying was there these guys were trapped
and there's this perception that people
have of trap Traders it's going to cause
a complete reversal of the market it the
reversal is going to be shorter than you
think right it's not something that's
going to cause
um
you know an all-day Trend it's going to
be shorter Trends but I mean you can
still trade them you know Five Points 10
points maybe even more sometimes you
know that one that happened at uh after
the cash open obviously it set as the
high of the day but I mean you know
there's much other factors coming in
after that I wouldn't consider these 500
contracts that traded up here enough to
consider that the uh
you know important enough to say oh
there's truck Traders up here you know
and it was the high of the day I mean
here we had the Trap Traders at 27 and a
half
and you know the market did sell down to
05 and a half when we get down five and
a half
um you know 20 points
but again you know the move to have you
had getting short off this just
recognizing hey I got aggressive buying
and it's not Market's not going anywhere
right because if you're Progressive
buying that's what you got to realize
strong aggressive buying it needs to be
followed through if it's not followed
through
it's probably
not as strong as you think now here
later right this is you don't see any
imbalances in here but what you're
seeing is stopping volume so you do have
obviously aggressive buying people
buying the offer but it's not showing up
as buying imbalances Okay so
you know trap Traders it it comes in
more than one form all right so
hopefully
this sort of gets you thinking more
about how you can recognize trap Traders
and more importantly how to take
advantage of them in the market so if
you enjoyed this video
I know it might be a little bit
confusing especially if you're sort of
new to the concept of trap Traders and
you know how they form in the market you
know either through aggressive trading
or through absorption
um you know just
think about it a little bit concentrate
on it you know if you see it and you'll
you'll understand it trust me it'll come
to you eventually as second nature so
again I hope you guys appreciate these
videos
um you know my goal is to get you guys
familiar with order flow so things come
naturally right like you're
internalizing it just as like when
you're driving a car right the first
time you drive a car you may not
understand everything but you know after
a while you become very comfortable
right you can understand how to drive
down the road without getting into an
accident hitting another car all right
because you've internalized everything
and the same thing with with order flow
right if you start seeing things enough
times and especially you know putting in
your own screen time you'll get to that
point where
it just all makes sense to you so I hope
you enjoyed this video be sure to like
the video and subscribe to the channel
if you haven't already done so thanks
everyone bye bye